it is lifehacks 109 ah only human
this episode's gonna be sick yeah I
don't think my not better
well my more organized 9 a [ __ ] mint
my name you I have got so many [ __ ]
good life hacks here so I love
sandwiches
I just think sandwiches are God's gift
he says witnessed what I do to
sandwiches so it'd be banned from
pornhub y'all get to me is a non savory
ketchup it's a girl yeah that's the
closest I've ever felt to like it a
religious pulling towards a belief like
yoga is it is a savory pepper but I just
have this feeling like I'm being
bombarded with media that's just telling
me that like the next 10 years there's
gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back and
joined by none other than Johnny and
Youssef from propane fitness colonies it
is life hacks 109 tools approaches apps
and products for a productive and
efficient life and this episode is
brought to you by the protein works
thank you very much to the protein works
for sponsoring this episode
we are massive fans of Steel shakers if
you haven't transformed your life and
your training by moving from plastic to
steel you have too much more time for
changing unbelievable they're giving
away five for free all you need to do is
share this episode post on your social
is put it in a group chat however you
want to and then either show me the
screenshot by DMing me or tag me in your
share and I'll pick five people to win
one of these and yeah they'll post them
up between us we've used a lot of
protein trackers yeah and this you want
it was you only need one it's beautiful
nothing works when you leave a plastic
protein shaker behind the car seat
overnight in UCI in your gym bag I mean
it doesn't fix the metal protein checker
doesn't fix that problem cuz I've been
washing it in this it's easier to wash
your 100% and it's nice it catches a
little bit condensation on the out of it
one outside of it when it's cool so
that's what I like the most about as you
pick it up for now it's cold these feels
: it you know like mid training session
or after training session house just you
don't want like like a lukewarm plastic
you want a cold man plastic warms it up
doesn't it it's if it tastes the plus
it's also just something you feel like
it like a kid at nursery drink out
faster you there's rental cups with you
squash in you go the little bottles of
milk but it was milk like
so yeah anyway if you want with if you
want to win one just share the UPS or
tag me and share that Chris will X on
all social media or also before I forget
people on YouTube links to everything
we're talking about will be in the show
notes below but if you follow the links
you will be supporting the podcast at no
extra cost yourself because we are on
the Amazon affiliate scheme thank you
so yeah until I fax we've prepped quite
hard for this episode so we have got
some [ __ ] ah
any you man this episode's gonna be sick
yeah I don't think mine are better -
they were my more organized line a
[ __ ] mint mindin you yours aren't the
same okay so I'm gonna go faith in you
yeah I am going to go first
and first one is when you take a
screenshot on iphone yeah the corners of
the screen when the screenshot pops up
you can just press on the screenshot
open it out and you'll see on the
outside you have the frame where you can
pull the crop in yep so you can crop
naturally from that so I didn't know
that you couldn't just you didn't just
have to go back into photo editor
afterwards take a screenshot so do it
now take screenshot on your phone and
then if you press on the picture and
then the corners of the image you can
pull down and crop from there so you can
zoom in you can zoom it's a square you
can just take the particular areas out
of it so you don't actually need to make
up I also did a little line bar you've
drawn on it but that's okay but yeah I
mean game change it there we go
right Johnny hot potato hot potato I
always got undo my racket banger is it
proper oh well at least it is for me so
ladies prepare ladies it can be okay if
that's what you want so ladies Johnny
because I'm know so I order a lot of
coffee shop coffee okay and I've come to
the conclusion that in my humble and
correct opinion filter coffee is the
best thing to order right Dean VMD
agrees with me or the GED depending on
your preference so filter coffee so
people are like americano or whatever
like if you want a coffee with milk
right order a filter coffee now there
are two scenarios when you order filter
coffee one is that there is filter
coffee in the machine great winning
fantastic the second is that they've run
out of filter coffee what are we to do
well what they almost always offer to do
is to make you an Americano which is
more expensive for the same price
interesting huh so what place have just
never ordered americano what places do a
fill the coffee Starbucks right not cafe
Nero preyed upon Jay and some Costas
they're rolling it out in Koster okay
thank you spent coffee company will do
it as well there'll always be pressure
that do they yeah so just a fella coffee
is the cheapest coffee on the menu or
all also almost always the nicest and if
they don't have it you just get a more
expensive coffee for the same free
upsell free upsell awesome I love it use
it very good speaking of drinks I'm
heartbroken I brought these guys some
kombucha which is the fermented tea and
I'm seeing three bottles almost full so
just to be clear
I've drank out of that one yeah as you
can see the seal the seal and this has
been broken as is mine but the top has
been placed very firmly back on because
this carbonated vinegar pussay for a big
creative expensive conviction I thought
you know what I'm gonna the only Savior
AZ saving race about this entire thing
seasons two months so they 70 pounds of
kombucha only saving grace about this
whole having after drinking now is it's
nice if you have a look right there
that's actually the modern wisdom logo
is on the lid of it but yeah okay so
it's not come beat you so it's not
accomplish it but I'm on a gut health
kick and then that we can we can talk
about that later at the moment you've
heard us discuss Alfred a month which is
basically a way to get you away from
your trackpad away from your mouse and
fully into your keyboard I have gone a
step further recently and there are two
apps that I'm using vim iam and shortcut
both of these these are so beam up is a
very big part so what what these are
lying to do is never need to use the
trackpad again now you might think well
it's only a few centimeters away why
but dude you move the trackpad yeah if
your hands are just on the keyboard
you're locked in your doing work you
type in your doing stuff you're focused
soon as you start using the trackpad it
always leads down at horrible garden
paths - naughty youtube videos youtube
videos whatever it is you just or
scrolling yeah so this forces you did so
what what this tool is quicker as well
when you use shortcut Vivien these are
the same up but one is for specific to a
web browser and one is for the general
okay fat Apple and I'll bring in art
this in the native version of Catalina
the new Mac OS in November or October
interesting it's a bit I'd bring it up
specifically for disabled people and
voice-activated control but you can do
it with your keyboard what it does is
anything that's possibly clickable on
your screen suddenly has a letter
assigned to it unless it or two letters
so you press like the special key in it
goes mmm and then you just so like fa is
close the thing p.m. is minimize this
and CD would be click on this link or
whatever and suddenly you just the
sensation is incredible because it feels
like more and more you just at one with
your device and there's no gaps and
faffing around with trying to access
with it's the polar opposite to when you
ask your when you see your mum googling
something single finger single finger
she's typing HTTP into the Google search
bar move the mouse over and she'll
capitalize that is by pressing the caps
lock on and on yeah yeah do you ever
worry that you are breaking your laptop
well you've done it you haven't broken
your laptop I'm not saying you are I'm
just saying
does it concern do you you ever think
maybe it's a bit much these jailbroken
apps coming out of basra I see yeah it's
not a system tweaks it's not it's not a
jail there are some that I'd love that
but do you drink it didn't you use the
migration assistant to backup you have
to restore your new laptop from your old
laptop and you got a new laptop inherit
some of the problems that you're all
that up yeah I did so there was
something there was something chronic
and pathological about your last lap
laptop there was which is now being
passed down
none of those things make it to life
hacks in the experimental phase don't
worry finian don't know what those
things are
yeah we don't need so we may Stefan haha
because what if that thing hmm is Alfred
that will be the biggest nasty twit twit
plot twist release their just a dip just
released 4.0 so Vinny MV I weigh an EU n
I've been told to wait her for point I
offered yeah VI m e um the I am I um I
um and short cut
yeah these are tools that are designed
for coders and programmers who just they
just have their lives correct they just
got it right it's a good way to look at
like designing for the extremes often
means that when you dial that Bacchus
it's still effective right we all want a
little bit more a formula one isn't it
yeah okay so hold on to the bottom of
the steering wheel in a crash this is
something that's taken from NASCAR
drivers so I was listening to a Joe
Rogan podcast from maybe a year ago and
he was talking to a very famous NASCAR
driver his dad had been a NASCAR driver
and this I knew that actually talking
about concussion for quite a while
because they suffer with it soup about
these this absolutely locked in to these
cars right the seat molded around them
essentially and they're twenty five
point harness and all this stuff but yet
so they were talking about the fact that
he rolled his truck Reming this guy
essentially crushes cars for a living
and he rolled this truck just on normal
streets so driving along like I think
it's Christmas Day perhaps even going to
his fake family's house or something
like that rolled his truck on some ice
and it's the cars rolling he forgot the
first rule as far as he was concerned of
being in a spinning car which is hold
the bottom of the steering wheel and his
arms as soon as you start to spin your
arms will go he'll be like the Team
America signal you know yeah so your
arms will just start flailing everywhere
and he was saying he had the window open
so you
is the window of his big truck open car
starts roller like sausage rolling
sideways and his arm goes out of the
window out of the open window and then
he pulls it back in just before the car
lands on that side so you got to think
if this car spinning around in your arms
are flailing everywhere the chance of
your arm getting crushed pretty high
holding onto the bottom of the steering
wheel so gripping the bottom like that
was great benchpress reverse grip bench
press yeah I mean you could go a mixed
grip but um you know it's a short short
endurance but you're holding the bottom
apparently locks all your organs in a
lot more keep your arms in tight yeah
very sorry oh you can practice it now if
you're listening at home we don't Terra
bicep listen listening at home just in
my better than hold on at the bottom of
the steamer if you're driving just try
it now hold on the bottom the steamer if
your house secured you feel within the
confines of driving safety on the road
yeah still I mean 10 into for the most
part but if you stationary you can go
kind of like a half 5 and I'm laughs no
because just in case there's a crush
yeah yeah
cause really then also always drive like
that just in case then you're always
ready the trouble is a guy who crashes
professionally for a living has the the
moment of clarity in a collision to go
if you think about it now like I was I
was considering this the other day you
told you right like you need to drill
holding on the bottom the steering wheel
yeah which means the being in lots of
car crashes yeah which is obviously
unadvisable however I felt like if I was
ever in a car crash I think after him
maybe a second of spinning I'd be like
right [ __ ] yeah hold the bottom of the
steering wheel I am in an accident I am
having an ass [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah if
anyone's got any advice about how to
brace and stuff like so I've been in a
couple of car crashes where I've known
the impact was coming and I don't know
the theory behind whether or not you
should brace relax do whatever like I
don't know that so if anyone knows
tell us you should put the clip of the
Khaleesi I wrote in a fighter jet video
brilliant just go full bar saw that like
full up tension
yeah but yeah oh you mean like are you
more likely to injure yourself Divac
mischeif yeah because you said like
ripping up or something like hernia nice
they tested um did you ever see that
thing on channel 4 where they crashed a
plane crash a real plane into the desert
but they have loads of crash dummies in
it and they split tested brilliant split
tested sitting upright or sitting in the
brace position yeah if you sit upright
you hit the seat concussed yourself and
you just burn while your concussed and
don't know what's happening if your
brace you snap your ankles but your
conscious why'd you snap your uncle
because if the force goes down through
your uncle you are cracking so I have to
get that conscious but conk out the
plane or the [ __ ] swings and
roundabouts you know you need there lot
of upper-body strength
big bad rip to see out in front of you
but you're fine yeah it's a quick fact
about that it makes me really furious is
there was a recent plank rush where I
can't remember where it was but the the
plane landed in some water was on fire
people at the front managed to get out
people at the back didn't get out and
tyanna died it was in the news like a
few weeks ago
and the reason that the people at the
back couldn't get out is because the
people at the front we're trying to take
their luggage off oh my gosh oh my it
makes me so angry but I don't know what
the I've just got me Judy freeing in the
back I've got I've got a 200 sleeve
offensive Hedges menthol in the sea like
it's gonna be in the scene I just think
that worries me the most about
situations like that is not me it's the
people I'm with yeah because I feel like
all I would do in practice is just push
yeah I mean like angle down and then go
do it you know what you're really good
at doing
technically a deadlift to push if you
think about it push the floor away I
mean as far as the IPF like yeah yeah
yeah go for a push-pull competition but
yeah so that many as men you could take
the bench presses though the pool
telogen throws it right Johnny Europe
this is a changing tack but get a toasty
machine so we could George Foreman for
bread for bread so I love sandwiches
I just think sandwiches are God's gift
of food enough thickness bagels
you know I'm half thickness beggars you
says witnessed what I do to sandwiches
there's so much of a chance lucky so it
would be banned from pornhub Aryan who
destroys so because you think like Tosun
sandwich I that's something that's
reserved for you know if you're in
somewhere that makes them I can't know
what I mean what think how fabulous more
fun can be so I want a couple of bits of
info from you here okay
I want the toasting machine that you use
and everyone that is important I want
you top to toasty recipes including prep
okay so the first toasting machine I
bought shorted the circuitry in the
house
sounds like a good service I want that
this is the thing is see you'll think
you look at the toast machine lined up
and they're always in like because
they're not very common because not many
people have them there was in the corner
of the shop and they'll be like a 15
quid one a thirty quid one and then like
a ninety five quid one so you get the 95
cool when you think like it's just
[ __ ] toasted branded yeah like it's
hot bread with bits in did you get the
lovely five quid oh no no I got the I
got the cheapest one and be proud of me
I think I got the cheapest one yeah well
then progressive shorted the house Goss
have loads it was Argos yeah isn't that
like the first thing you think of when
you buy deciding to get a like basic
kitchen plan two paragraphs are always
good for the mid-range kit kitchen
appliance for anything well so that's
the lesson go for the mid-range one yeah
the interesting thing about it is you
have to butter the bread from the
outside yeah she can't butter the inside
of the sandwich what so we only can
because everybody was just melt moist on
the outside
stick to the yes you've got a cream I
think is pointing to lubricate to the
ideas problem where they toast machine
is the bread sticking to the hot plate
so you could use oil spray in the
surface of the good then you can a virus
yeah yeah because what makes the toasty
oh I've just gotten you like nice and
browned and golden it is the butter yeah
fillings I found so far actually the
more creative you are with this it just
comes back to bite you like there is a
reason why harmonies toasty is so highly
circular some fails think so don't add
anything like any source stuff after
what imagine mayonnaise of the author
because it just goes it like separates
into its component parts II yeah they're
like refining oil
yeah it's minion and like obviously no
like tomato and things I'm not a mark
because so the other thing is the Martha
you've got a really clamp down on it so
you put the you put the thing you put
your it what is it what's the solution
push well yeah well actually it's a
pinch not get on top of it no no no will
be a snap it
no no not so you put the bread in yeah
you do the thing like what I do with
most things that you think might require
a bit of force be gonna break it
see you're like just feel it attention
because obviously I overfill them so I
put too much filling me all right grab
it and I'm like you squeeze it once I
know something close you might as you
get the clip on Turner Anya house in
short and success and then they're the
their own the level advancement they
have is to lights green and red exactly
this one has there's no dial there's
members of on switch and then a green
light and a red light and somehow
they've decided that they know the time
before all toasties
to be toasted so reversal time so the
lights red and then it goes green but
because it's like be like I want to say
like a minute
45 seconds you get a bit distracted and
you'll look at it and realize there's no
sound no no buzzer no no there's nothing
no no no also up you have to literally
stare at it to you it's like being green
for 30 seconds yeah ham and cheese is
what angle Jersey view wafer-thin home I
quite like um Lee Adama cheese you had
that before
is that the stuff with the holes it yeah
it's sweet bit yellow yellow packaging
yeah yep
um but [ __ ] delicious what's hosting
machine cuz I'm gonna have to link this
up I think it's I think it's Breville
see for me yeah Breville sandwich maker
sounds like a legitimate from your
description I don't know if I would buy
that model I think we should have a
German with a buzzer oh no my egg boiler
as a child shouts at me when I I think
that's because that's quite important
that it but it does up there I think no
more because nothing go on fire it just
seems ruins the egg but if he's toast a
toasty slightly too long you get a bit
you the breads a bit browned but they
feel after for ages within the bread go
on fire they hear it you leave a phrase
that's like if you if you leave the oven
on for too long
well doesn't it there's no alarm on the
oven but so I like they're brilliant
they're really cheap and if you are like
looking for something to have if you'll
have sandwiches in the house just have
to toast these four constantly it's a
good point man I heard last week at a
refeed day and I was walking through a
stir
look twice and so it didn't burn always
happy they came flew with a cake and saw
some extra-large crumpets Oh mate I love
how big like I think I like this on yeah
pretty big like almost almost is it so
well nothing frisbee so the way I the
way that I toasted mine was I had to put
it in and then take the both of them in
then take the full things out to rotate
hundred and eighty degrees then put them
back in and do the other side but then
what I chose to do was have an
extra-thick single side of butter and
just put one on top of the other ice ah
delicious because both ends obviously
the outside of a crumpet is the crusty
as bit right and also I think unions
yeah I put these two outside [ __ ] loads
of butter really salty butter oh my god
see the downside of a toasty machine is
it can only be used for toasties because
if the plates are shaped like a toaster
you like crimps yeah there's a bread and
you know like an a4 bit of bread in -
mm-hmm into - you know what I mean that
you know exactly what I mean like a for
white Warburton's bread into - best of
both so I see I use actually this is
another tip don't for [ __ ] sake use
normal bread Oh God okay is too thick
you need to buy thin because they just
get like a supermarket own-brand
toasty bread compresses more interesting
I look at our best rock tonight toasty
bread is cool toasty bread it's more
where you get Danish as well where it's
like about you lick it does alter you
turn it it's interesting about you sell
about like the three price ranges
because I do think that applies to all
kitchen appliances and I've got I have a
pressure cooker in fact have we
discussed this on previous life yes yeah
okay so you'll have known that my I went
from rice cooker to pressure cooker 100
pounds instant pot there is one for
about two thousand pounds that you can
get is it come with a chef yeah I feel
like it's it is like super there's a
glory hole isn't yeah there must be some
some business going on there but remove
the keratin penis cooking so today my
life hack is something that I think the
three of us need to start doing which is
this counseling is someone gonna have a
pillow no oh yeah counselor well I know
let's go there's your how coach yeah
coach was like everyone used to do
counseling family therapy or some poor
but doodle poll so now yes what is it
this is this is well because when you
doodle pull this is when you've got you
you got between three people
you're all like oh we need to do a thing
on Tuesday
oh no I'll come to Tuesday but I can do
Tuesday morning no I can't
I've got okay how about Thursday I said
man I can't do this and you end up
having this like long conversation to
try and organize a date whereas doodle
poll gets you you all get sent out a
list of times you take the ones that you
can do and then it collides and finds
the overlaps that says like currently
similar so calendar things like a
booking service for two people
yeah whereas do the poll if you're like
organizing a stag to us and so I used it
from first acting did you open eyes you
epic that is awesome
is there a referral code is it free it's
free it's free up to like a certain
number of okay users uh something yeah
okay just met and then just make a new
email yeah that's awesome
that's a [ __ ] really good service
right right oh well this one this one's
a [ __ ] game changer if you don't know
about it
um share Auto share your Instagram story
to your Facebook story this is the most
free games that I'm ever gonna give you
on life hacks right it's the equivalent
free games is wearing these sleeves to
squat so if you are on your phone if you
don't know I'm talking about going to
foam going to Instagram swipe right so
that you open up your Instagram story
little button at the bottom that is
story settings setting story settings
and then scroll right to the bottom and
it's just a little nonchalant toggle
that says share story to Facebook that
allows you to automatically share what
have you put on your Instagram story on
your Facebook story and no one no one
actually looks after the Facebook story
because who gives a [ __ ] about Facebook
stories however I have about 15,000
followers in between friends and
followers on mine and I'm getting just
over a thousand views on Facebook
because Facebook a desperate for the
open race so they need it yes so they
drives they're driving it really hard
and it will auto pull through polls so
if you put a poll on Instagram
it'll bring the ability across one thing
it doesn't do which is slightly
frustrating especially for what a lot of
people in marketing will do is it
doesn't transfer across swipe ops
because you can't swipe off on Facebook
to go to a link which is a little bit
annoying solo at the time I'd be like
using your podcast or whatever like
clickable just know that you just got
this thing at the bottom path stupid
yeah bit irritating but some of this
stuff works like some of the polls work
and some of the questions work and
things but it is the freest gains you're
ever gonna get and you can share if
you've if you're on a business account
maybe even you're on a personal but I
doubt it if you're on a business account
you can share it to a fan page so our
lights they're looking after our club
nights they'll be going around taking
Instagram stories and stuff like that
but our fan page is a massive or
couldn't I found pages of Massachusetts
where the albums get uploaded to and
we're finding that we're matching our
Facebook our Instagram reach on Facebook
just through the stories and you're
already doing it you're already
recording the content and you once you
press that button once free gamesman the
game shut your game change Johnny so I
have one that is that will upset people
so I'm going to do this one initially
then I'll do a proper one who's it going
to upset Russell I think so it's a [ __ ]
thing to do it's a [ __ ] thing to do and
I think it'll upset people especially
people who care about the environment
okay we go so strap yourself this it
using it this works I've tested that it
works and I've observed it happen put
your not no not that you can strangle a
[Laughter]
thumb doesn't have enough girth together
you probably need to just struggle one
yeah although I feel like it could
properly you can I try yours a hot-water
bottle and if you if you let if you let
go for a minute you know what's up yeah
but really what don't have the brace but
[ __ ] resistance in them um but yes
strangling a dolphin will also be quite
hard if they difficult yeah you can't
get it into when that
mostly neck squeeze in the bakery you
can't get it in a like a full-nelson or
a half-nelson are over I had a teacher
at school that you saw argue that
everybody has their price for everything
he was adamant someone went I disagree
[Laughter]
but I bet you can guess
okay look him do the voice all right
okay see what everyone has that price
and I'm and someone went no like I
wouldn't I wouldn't kill a puppy anyway
I bet you would
I bet you will ten million ten million
and he was like we strung their dolphin
you kill a dog know that you would
hundred million it was we were like six
one high so would you agree with him
everyone has that price for anything
going down there anyway to your to your
life back so you know how when you are
in Sainsbury's right and you're getting
something and you go to the till but not
self-service go the till and there's
someone processing you shopping for you
and they say would you like a bag and
you say yes and then they say that'll be
five peas are okay and you go yes if you
want to point to five P charge there's
dick moves what you do is you wait for
them to process the payment and then you
say oh can have a bag please
and they'll give you one for free and
they won't then set up a new transaction
to process the five P because the
processing fee would just a road the
five P anyway one day they understand
the backend processing fees well know
efficiently I know but like they're not
going to trickle down was it there's a
customer waiting said there's a customer
waiting and you eat or you're out to
leave your app and you're like this is I
say this isn't a like 10:00 p.m. on a
Monday tactic is it when there's ten
checkout operation I know your CP just
like you eat during normal busy times it
depends if there's a protocol that
they've just told everyone blank
like if someone asks for after it
happened one time right how come one
time to meet and I was away she can
charge me for the bag and but it's a
dick move because I understand why is it
about environment to do us well but the
whole point of that so that it's a
heisenbugs the goofy and tax isn't it
designed to offset the negative
externalities of the plastic and the so
it's designed to discourage someone from
getting the bag
what I'm doing is getting a bag anyway
I'm not and they're couraging people
publicly to do it I just say so I'm
saying I found it I found it work do
with it what you will yeah I don't think
it's the right thing to do necessarily
but I've tested it since happen the
first time and it does still work you'd
the upgrade the [ __ ] upgrades do that
actually this would this wouldn't work
but I actually think that this is a
better way to do what you talked about
that's this killer dolphin it's strike
get it all fit into a half-nelson so you
can get it in a big net one moment
grab like that and then the solution is
of my favorite thing if you know when
they go out oh yeah like a bug then go
say yes hmm would you like a hand with
your packing yes ring I just say and if
not I just said would you mind giving me
a hand with my packing which is there on
languages back at them even though I
actually think especially as they might
have cycled that out now but it's just I
mean it's so ingrained in them that's
like the Russian trigger code and
they're just immediately start packing
your [ __ ] away and you can just do
whatever you want right if they are
particularly surly so what I do is I'll
pretend that there's something I've
forgotten and just go off on a little
walk um I'll just I've just forgotten
something would you mind just packing my
bags while I go like an entire thing
just blind know if that's so certainly
that you come back in there go where's
the thing that you've forgotten five
dollars well do like the body pack the
bags that's true [ __ ] on me
was a really
so Alan Partridge scissor dial where he
becomes a checkout lady for a day
mmm brilliant you probably were able to
go on YouTube Eli's brilliant cool right
Seth you got one 1/2 that's gonna get me
in trouble
fun that one's just got Johnny and I
guess I'm gonna get like picketers and
the whole thing
vegans okay dolphin lovers I have found
a way to shed you all iMessages Wow okay
come on man so go to shortcuts which
used to be a third-party app there's now
been acquired by Apple and it is it I
just give me a settings so you download
it from the App Store but Apple have
made it and in the next iOS it's gonna
be shortcuts shortcuts it's gonna be the
new way it's gonna be like one of the
native bits of art and it's a it's an
automation service for iPhone what it
allows you to do is I'll give you a few
examples of things that it can do so all
of the text that I've sent Johnny over
the past the problem is obviously having
to respond because the only way that you
can respond by scheduling is predicting
the question yeah all the tests just mmm
that's nice that's interesting I also
think that oh this is Gary we're getting
really down it's like is this like a
chatbot but just for you just yeah he's
gotta make you know actually chatbot
it's just messages that Yusuf's typing
really so sure shortcuts other things
that can do it can resume the latest
book that you're listening to at nan
Kazakhs ping scheduling hi messages how
they'll do it showed you our message
it's just one of the shortcuts on there
let me see you can add to one the list
let me see
you cannot let me see you can play come
on I mean I can't see now you can play
the most recent playlist so and also you
can create a smart playlist oh is that a
widget is that in your widgets on it
yeah okay just once happen in it so so
can you schedule you showed you on our
message to me for the next part in five
minutes time okay cool that's gonna be
good if it doesn't right in five minutes
time you know that
can you can also create a smart playlist
of like the last 50 songs that you added
to your iTunes and it'll auto actually
use action but okay
so it would be nice if I did the send
delayed message man I have got so many
[ __ ] good life hacks here I've got
loads we're gonna have to do life hacks
one time maybe we shouldn't have like a
single payment of nine nine nine nine
nine and a month although I [ __ ] 99
took 9,500 pounds right it's only
shortcuts for a thing yeah go get your
it is it on that funnel and Atkins the
only time I'm allowing you to put it
allowed in a podcast okay so I think I
have message notifications on that's
good see that's [ __ ] good that double
to deep down okay so unsplash.com is it
unsplash.com run splash comm so splash
axles and pixabay as though so everybody
everybody wants to use everybody wants
nice stock photos that they can use
whether it's for marketing or just for
cover photo for some event that you
making on Facebook or whatever it is
when splash calm is without a doubt the
best place to find well curated stock
photos so a lot of photographers across
the internet have taken mint photos of
random stuff whether it be meditating or
a photo of the spine or a cool photo of
coffee or anything when splash calm
search whatever is that you're looking
for I guarantee they're a bit hipstery
some of the photos they are a little bit
but this that they over deliver on cool
and edginess which for a stock photo
probably brings it tuned about normality
yeah but you know stock photos are so
clinical okay yes exactly
Chris these are brilliant these free yes
all of them rightly free grab it this is
I sit so pixels we spoke while that
wonderful no video to pixels
PMD so being they even it's so petals is
what I've always used it's very similar
to this like the formatting and
everything so to meditation even has
even has
the save some of the same photos the
search meditation or productivity I've
searched Jim Jim
are just insane Mint photos of like cool
shoes big Bronto monsters large human
yes sir so yet when splash calm like it
you can also a really [ __ ] good thing
is if you've got what was that story app
that we came up with the cover the one
that has the ripped rip paper
[ __ ] oh yeah VM DPM DS gesturing
from my memory anyway unfold unfold
yes fasting unfold has been built into
it so unfold we already featured it a
nice way of making Instagram stories
were very curated one fold has built
into it you can either add a photo from
your gallery take a photo or
automatically search unsplash and just
pull a photo in without saving it to
your phone that [ __ ]
there's a couple of wordpress apps we do
you usually do that as well that's
lovely but they must have an API that
just allows you to so can I pick it back
of that yeah yeah cool there's a mac app
called zoomy with two M's that is an
aggregator of pixabay pixels and splash
what's it called zoomy 0 om my and it's
it's 12 pounds and it's a lifetime
license yeah I think so and you just so
changed applicator all the photos it
splits them by paid and free photos and
I just like I prefer having a native
money blown away by your head completely
I use pixels two three days a week
unspotted is a lot of that is game
changing man some of your ads now we
should do by touch Martin that's Frank
was a thang if you don't cheat sheet
rate alright Frank the tank Frank the
tank right zoom yeah oh well going back
the other way
broken it no I thought that was probably
Johnny your turn
who's not gonna have that computer none
of us are going to have this
can I have Satan's vinegar pit can I
have someone come on Dapeng go thank you
thank you acting like it would you like
it no no Johnny waiting I'm sure I
decide which one to pick okay oh this
one so you may have heard the you know
you like ever has a to-do list to do
this right so everyone has like
somewhere like a bit bit paper or in an
app whatever and you have the problem
where you sit down you're like what am I
gonna do like how do I pick from this so
some people say pick one thing to do per
day some people say have three important
tasks to do but the natural reaction to
that is like I ever I need to go and
like take this thing back to the shop or
whatever see a lot of things get missed
from that framework so the one that
something that I've I read about a long
time ago use it when I was working as an
accountant actually quite a bit but
start using it again recently is 531
it's not the strength training program
five three one four productivity so much
the squat bench and deadlift and said
you have one key task the most important
think of that day which would be if
that's what we got done so the
successful day you don't have three
medium importance of you know the next
three things that would be on your
priority list and you do five admin
level [ __ ] tasks how do you segment
them out
what do you mean so how do you choose
what falls into because some tasks may
be able to be categorized into a see
what so admin stuff is like stuff that
you probably wouldn't even normally put
on your to-do list I really low level
things but sometimes also things that
like you would just let slide because
they're not they're not that important
but still matter when they add up so
triangle examples like make a phone be
like someone you need to call something
you need to take back an errand you need
to runs
that's what stuff most important thing
is like the thing of the most impact so
if you does that happen first ideally
you do that thing first yeah so like if
you're a involved in business or or
whatever you run your own business
something that impacts your revenue or
move your business forward if you were
an employee it's like the thing that you
might lose a job if you don't do and
then three things after that would just
be the next three things on your list
the most I found that to be a nice
balance between like firstly if you take
off all the five things you still feel
like and get it might smash in it even
though they're not important and by the
end of the work week you've done 25
admin level tasks from me in a natural
ratio of those involve tasks as well
isn't it
nice like it is there a log or like a
little if you search like 531 for
activity method and the best app I've
found to use this on big lifts to big
lifts - no sir it's the most strangling
a no todoist
so I know you don't like - no no you
like the things and all the sort of
stuff but todoist allows you to color
code or categorize your tasks blue red
or yellow so blue is my on my admin
tasks yellow is my medium importance in
red as the most important so I'll
actually go if you might to do this and
I'll pre categorize them
so the start of the day I just literally
click and drag five things three things
one thing done day scheduled that's all
I do
that's a good way to do it's good Seth
this is really really related to what
Johnny's just said about to-do list I
use wonder list but both apps have this
feature which is a quick capture hotkey
so sort of things so this thing are
great okay so all three whether you were
to do is wonder list or things use it
they all have this feature and I know my
life has to be very techy today but
there'll be a keyboard shortcut if
wonder list it's command shift W comes
up with a bar you tap in the task that
you need to do and I think with to do it
has the best version of this where if
you put like a symbol of art or hashtag
or whatever you can then allocate it to
a certain list and you can target as
high medium or low priority and then
it's just in your system so you don't
have to open up the app or anything you
can just be in the middle of something
your eyes did that think okay
tag urgent in folder work you smart
schedule if you also like if like if you
to say
if I control and haven't logged in to
things on any long mini laptop so I
think command T is todoist pretty sure
so command T and then it'd be like login
to unsplash every Monday Wednesday
Friday yeah natural is a natural
language so T Agra fort a if you're
interested in this sort of stuff if this
is kind of really getting your juices
flowing the mi goat wasn't hard
yeah it doesn't splash love you um the
episode that did with tiago forte is the
[ __ ] bible on this like is just a
month stone it's quite a bit about it
isn't it really does yet but a
frictionless capture for to do lists i
think is the using a smart capture one
thing that things has is called things
helper which is where it uses a smart
capture so let's say that you're on an
e-mail and you use - ctrl + space to
open up the capture but control option
space pulls in the title of the page
that you're on on a website and then put
the URL into the description so let's
say that you need to reply to an email
you just says it whichever whichever app
is at the front yes and it'll just pull
that through but typically it's used for
websites so it'll just pull down and
it'll toggle it with the thing at the
top but you can change the name of the
page and then it'll do you to use i'm
guessing you do the evernote email
address when you you know they've you
know the things that we use sitting
sifting through emails beautifies
missing right for you explain this like
just what what the feature is so if you
haven't have if you have ever known
evernote account you have an email
address associated to that having an
account that allows you to send an email
to having a think to inbox so I have an
Alfred shortcut which is I type a ever
enter and it sends the email and files
it away to my Evernote
that's lovely well as in it so you have
to have the email open yes if it so what
I'm sitting through my emails are Carmen
is at iographer water it's like give me
the action it delay it or reference
something yeah this is an email app
that's purely designed or our mouth yes
I think it's like a game for jima kind
of others it's a standalone thing and
there's buttons next area are I okay
it says purely designed around that
someone made a game for Gmail to get you
to inbox zero where you like have to
swipe emails from 13 that's funny it's
this defender for emails yeah so there's
an equivalent for this which is sent to
Kindle so you can turn on an accepted
email address on your Kindle device it's
actually on your Amazon account and then
anything which you receive from that
email address if the attachment can be
opened by Kindle it'll automatically add
it to your library on all your devices
so let's say that someone sends you oh
hi MA I've just ripped the Newmark
manson book or someone sent me or
whatever whatever all you do take that
email forward it to like Christa
Williamson Dadda Dadda Dadda at Kindle
calm mm-hm and all of your devices will
have that document on there do use
whisper sync no because I don't tend to
buy books that I also listen to either
have them I turned up a mom on or
another that's a good if you if you like
in the car if you're reading a book in
the morning you want to continue this
another way to work well something with
a couple of books syncs your place on
all of you I'm gonna do a slightly short
one out so um if you are listening to
house music in the gym and you're doing
some isometric holds that Sadie holding
a plank or you need to be holding a
stretch and you need to know how long
that's a holding it for thirty seconds
listening to house music almost all
house music is written at between about
hundred and twenty four hundred and
twenty-eight beats per minute which
means that every hi-hat hit or every
other beat is about a second so if
you're listening to music you don't need
to look at the clock just count every
other beat and that's going to count you
in seconds can you place an example yeah
sure so if in less than seven seconds
from this he's gonna pull us in fact
this is gonna pull this on YouTube
alright so um but yeah every alert every
other beat every beat is one second
almost exactly and by using that as a
cadence for doing whatever
isometric hold stretches
anything video so headlines really don't
need to look in there you go
excellent excellent Jenny so this one is
actually influenced by listening to your
podcast so James clear and then re
reviewing my notes on atomic habits life
but I think the mistake that people make
with building habits and behaviors is
they make it too general so we'll say
I'm gonna practice
I'm gonna build a habit of meditating
every day for example and what happens
is you will for a week meditate in the
morning and then something will happen
something happening and I'll do that
later I'll do later and then before you
know it you've lost you Street
completely of meditating so instead what
I've tried to focus doing is you drill
and build the what is almost like the
the lead indicator of that habit being
completed so like I will meditate in the
morning after making a coffee or
whatever but the biggest one for me was
the biggest change for me was trying to
achieve a calorie deficit right
something that we help a lot of people
do but saying I'm gonna track my macros
for 12 weeks or I'm gonna lose weight
like biggest for me the biggest lead
indicator of me getting my macros and
therefore being a calorie deficit across
the week is after I meditate in the
morning I sit and just plan in my
fitness pal what I'm gonna eat that day
probably so I track my macros in the
morning at the start of the day and all
that means is it's your best estimate
right like obviously things change but
all that means is that when you deviate
from what you tracked you immediately
think oh well I know I go back and
change my fitness well no I need to
adjust something later and that later
that later in the day so like what most
people do is they'll eat breakfast eat
lunch eat dinner tracking of [ __ ] I'm
over by 400 calories [ __ ] oh I better
adjust tomorrow or they're by the next
day you've had a night's sleep you've
kind of forgotten about that and then
you're over menu over your calories by
several thousand across the region so
they predict your calories earlier in
the day yeah so you just said most
people have a pretty routine like most
people things have a similar breakfast
like if you have like 40 rounds of
cereal and it
keeps away yeah banana yeah that's a
banana as well either love microbe
introduced been on a recently nice doing
a health kick
yes Johnson my crush doctor away smashes
this market avocado on the cereal oh
yeah we approach to have a bit of like a
sprinkled black pepper and lovely yeah
see how most people eat very similar
foods and usually the question mark is
dinner so if you best predict dinner and
if you listen to my previous like life
hack and you've got gusto then you just
pick the recipe card at the start of the
day got it all can I do - yeah
this is a present I got recently James
Haskell's cookbook right has barcodes on
the recipe pages the scanning media into
my fitness Baba that's great has listed
Matt's gonna become standard practice so
much yeah well yeah but you did you have
any idea how this powerful pick up
survey who you recipe books have the
macros on believe when you're trying to
put in like a third of a cup of flour
yeah I've been putting the end result in
you're putting in minor what are them
draw [ __ ] yeah yeah raw materials see
that's great who's James Haskell just a
rugby player ain't for me
I think forming your a prepared to make
you pose anymore big big dude
it's the standard route that career with
any X laboratory does no isn't it like
from the tree just cooking book it's
daytime TV I wasn't leaving see radio
Ulster today that's what several weeks
ago it'll be several weeks ago and
podcast on it I mean if it was the
podcast learned it's interesting
well we got you so two monitors has
changed my life a second display
well actually external display excellent
man's only second external display yeah
so how much better is having two
external displays than having one if you
got 10 Excel displays
I have the potential for it so I don't
have one I found my I acquired an old TV
my old Samsung TV like flatscreen I've
watched how much TV in years so I don't
really didn't know what to do with it
thinking to sell it and then I was like
there's an HDMI cable can I get an HDMI
to Thunderbolt or whatever it's called
knock-on HDMI on your mark
okay an air yeah so managed to find lil
Emerson I've had to buy 3 cables because
the first two I bought male-to-male and
then I bought like a a USB thinking
ahead of us about that was my stupidity
but eventually got the correct cable and
it's just instantaneous there's no delay
between thingies the quality's perfect
it's just like an extension of your
screen and all year I've when you have
document on one side and something
you're typing on the other for example
or something to reference or something
to do it's just been fantastic then if
you if you don't you're not doing a task
like that having your to-do list
maximized on that side yeah beautiful
you'd ever just maximize be focused Pro
yes with a signal it really exists like
right you're gonna do the other times
you can intercept them cut your order so
you can have like you can drag something
from there to there so I use better
touch tool for expanding their shortcuts
and things on mark which I highly
recommend it's like ten quid for like
for three years license I think and I've
got a short code where I'm a swipe left
from the edge of the trackpad and it
takes the window that's the frontmost
thing and maximizes it to the next
display so I throw it so if you it makes
the really displays including your
MacBook so the other display is what you
can use is any iPod or iPhone yeah using
an app called duet
now again you've been to Iowa well this
is made by my Apple developers AirPlay
Mirroring and screen mirroring nothing
you can do that as well but you have to
have the device that you mirroring to
you has to be capable of that it's just
a and that's only very mirroring it's
not it's not thanks for this flat
bracket so what do you ask allows you to
do and it will soon be included in the
default Apple thing is that you plug in
an iPhone or an iPod and you stand it up
and it just acts as another monitor okay
so other very small yeah that's a no
idea getting like this day you access
plus or something a massive phone yeah
yeah I mean it extra just with an iPhone
it's only used
for like something that's be focused
behind more a beer be focus pro that's
cool answer I'm gonna ride off the back
can I do - yeah oh actually just before
before you do ya better touch till just
on that note there's a new feature that
allows you you know how we mentioned a
few life hacks ago to improve in to turn
your light your truck that struck a
speed up to the maximum it can take it
past the currently rated a new spectrum
oh my god like this is sickening speed
so I send the screenshot it's like I
sent the screenshot of increased
trackpad sensitivity and then in
brackets after it says goes past current
like Apple settings a sent the
screenshot to daran daran said I wanted
to meet you yeah yeah you can also on
that theme this is for VMD you can use
an imac as an external display for a
macbook why would you not just
thunderbolt a thunderbolt no just in
case I want it so I'm extending from
your life hack there Yousef is convert
to a standing desk like I go in touch
with the guys who make the chair that
Joe Rogan has which is called the fully
capisco chair and they also make the
world's best standing desk which is nice
chair yeah it's very comfortably a lot
more like a subtle you need to just if
you're listening go and Google fully
capisco capi
sco di NGO and have a little look at it
it it looks like the maddest thing
everybody is ridiculously comfortable
it's a standing desk stool that you can
use from just a book typical seating
height to all the way above higher than
you are when you're standing and the
desk also is on actuators and with the
touch of a button you can go from
ceiling to standing you have preset
memory buttons on it as well you press
the button and it just rises up now it
isn't cheap that's the issue but if you
are working especially if this is going
to be the thing that you're going to sit
up for the rest of your life by the time
that this is up in facts - McGill went
out today so you'll have heard the
world's leading back pain specialist say
that move well and move often is the
best heuristic
to use for reducing back pain if you're
a knowledge worker if you work on that
you will have some degree of back
discomfort everyone does so moving from
seating to standing as seamlessly as you
can to me I'll explain this to you today
safe when I'm doing Pomodoro's now I do
two Pomodoro standing one Pomodoro
seating and as my alarm goes off and if
I need to change his press a book press
button or move and that's it and
standing all day to to seat into
standing moving around is making me feel
another thing as well so much more
energized when I stand up doing a
podcast standing up I'm able to use my
hands talk to at some time we should do
a live hype all three of us standing up
one day but do a podcast you have a
barbell stroked they do all the report
casts no they go round the country do
all that all the podcasts on so if you
want a cheaper version of that what I've
had for ages very dusk which is just a
big unit that you couldn't put on top of
any desk and that that becomes a
standing desk loads of adjustable height
as it goes up and forward yeah
also Kelly Starrett has a book called
desk-bound weight he's very empty
sitting it was very very antiseptic but
he has a sequence of like mobility
drills they're more like do some
movement movements you can do to
alleviate some of the symptoms of
sitting that work extremely well in
Pomodoro Brooks nicer Pomodoro breaks
are best use in my opinion as either
little quick meditation session or do
one of Kelly's Tourette's like rehab man
so I do I do learn the McGill the McGill
big three takes almost exactly four
minutes thirty for me to do one of the
movements it's about 15 minutes to go
all three done so you can get away
especially side plank side plank is
great hmm so I'm gonna do if I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do another one we are
approaching summer people going away on
holiday and you're gonna be going
through the airport this I only realized
it on my most recent trip and I've been
away quite a lot this year and this is
the discussion about where do you get
once you get into the
where do you get your food for the
flight from so I mean if you're not
buying food for a flight even if it's a
short one you need it because you're
left with like Ryanair's
toasty which is not a nice toast revel
sunny there always wet very soggy why
they wet very glum then sees that
process very context like wind I think
so it must be my Troy listen to this
[ __ ] get the Breville on him I mean
the Brad lips is that that is hot floppy
Brandon you have to pay extra for
Shirley as well you mean well yeah you
don't get it short haul flights you're
paying on top yeah long haul flights
even worse than that you the food that
young long-haul flights makes me almost
more hungry than before I yeah like it
is not specially if you've got an
analogy because what you get is a fruit
platter when they say fruit platter what
I mean is a bit of melon yeah
so yeah the I think you first off I need
to I need to preface this and create the
foundation that if you are going on a
plane you need some food mmm the best
approach for this is to get meal deal
right sailor ocular I want some water I
don't have to keep calling the lady over
also war's expensive on the plane mm-hmm
needs of water probably gonna get a
sandwich anyway so it's safer safer sort
of bet oh well if I've got that and may
as well get snack as well oops up WH
Smith meal deal $4.99 boots meal deal
399 and Boots meal deal boots is the
only store WH Smiths doesn't have this
boots has soaring pre buttered two
slices of olive you can only get the
single bar which is smaller in WH Smiths
but in Boots
one pound glass and you can get pre
buttered soaring slices I'm doing that
this week man GameChanger
I'm telling you I have a [ __ ] led you
my Amish buying tip oh so I buy a lot of
sandwiches like hyeondo sandwich
purchases so one of these are nice and
which heavy today this is the biggest
problem if you're someone who doesn't
unlike these to just maintain
all year round eating whatever the hell
you want and you have to actually
consider what you eat when you're buying
like a sandwich from Torrey Smith or
boots typically the calories are 400 to
600 and the proteins when we pretty low
that's pretty high proteins pretty low
so I have a 10 percent rule to try and
get that you want to get as close to
this temp same rule in general when
buying any meal in a place like this and
the 10% rule is calories 10 percent of
that number that's should be what you're
aiming for in grams of protein and the
closest you can get to that that is
pretty [ __ ] good like a grenade bar
is about 10 percent so they're not
always possible but you should be aiming
just aim together first of that so what
that ends up looking like is some
obviously chicken bacon salad kind of
sometimes they have it like a protein
booster don't they like a little
sometimes abadan a button all-day
breakfast it's [ __ ] good for that
it's actually not hash browns and all
that and all their breakfast they'll be
600 with maybe protein in the 20s yeah
if you got a chick in a bacon salad
usually something like that it'll be 400
with like a 35 gram protein or yeah and
really getting a very close yes good and
then if you want like a chocolate by
thinking how do i what do I do
because can increase my calories but not
then you get like chicken Raiders or
something [ __ ] like that but just on the
protein that's a very unappetizing
selection doesn't fit well yeah because
games because games because games I
remember being on a train
[Music]
I see Johnny's not even chewing anymore
he's just got empty pockets next to him
I get really annoyed in those situations
so I'll often buy because I think it's
important if you travel and got backpack
with it reserved sandwich so important
you never you never know when you're
gonna be caught in a situation like
you're in a museum
you hungry the cafe [ __ ] thank God
reserved sandwich I've got my yeah right
lady about you've got a slot you've got
one of those fancy fool but I do a
little backpack but you get so you go
with to some just simply to arty so I'm
using like a big smart water in
certainly buy some hot water smart you
should
one meter one you should take us through
Brazil on a on a new one I'm suggesting
new life hacks I want to hear from you
okay cool you go to get the thing the
two sandwiches and they say you know
it's only if you get packed me a crisps
no no I just want the sounds no I don't
want to [ __ ] ever but if you just
spend it over to throne yeah no I don't
on the meal appeal I just wanted to
sandwiches and the bottle of what excuse
me have you seen the percentage of
protein in these Saturdays I look like a
[ __ ] amateur this is the problem you
need to Johnny wet there'll be a better
deal than the thing that he's getting
the free kind of coke I'm not going to
buy the Telegraph to save three pence on
no I don't make the share box share bar
of Dairy Milk either I don't care if
it's on offer came here he answer you
views don't want that you just amok you
decentraland son digit [ __ ] okay go get
I think you know that he okay so that's
X no I'm good it's a half cup that's
because you are being forced to watch
the valley I was on it and I haven't had
to watch a single second you were on it
and I didn't watch an episode while
you're on it and now you're being forced
to watch it I was revising for example
it's everywhere every person who well
this is applied to a lot of people but a
lot of people who work nine to five jobs
the sort of rhythm that you're in the
hunger patterns that are created
typically people get hungry between 3:30
and 4:30 right what they usually do
vending machine muffin snack latte in a
biscotti or whatever yeah
yogurt and weight is the best a Greek
yogurt Greek yogurt a little bit banana
way or how do you make sure it dissolves
properly you don't get like part of
whisk it just give this a good skirt I
know what you mean yeah I'm gonna get a
better pocket of powder just give it a
good walks the for concern spoon what
you really need for this
a container which is larger than the
volume oh yeah dice which means because
there was not use your Ananda yogurts
that's a very good point because if
you're operating on like a full pot of
the orbit and the neutron balance skews
no it's just getting any going one
little bit of wind and it yeah it's the
killing you get those little air pockets
that come up and they fire the faggio
like a geezer and I sand it exactly we
were there we were um what'd you do in
that situation is you dig a trench open
the trench and then push the yogurt into
the trench then stir never try and stay
with the august's in your very the way
with the weight weight sitting on top
side okay so yeah so that is from the
things I found and feel free to add
something calories for satiety partly
the Greek yogurt with a bit away like
250 300 calories and leveling it up with
extra protein skier oh well yeah
obviously I ideally Icelandic skier from
directly from Iceland unfortunately
though it doesn't exist anywhere apart
darn on boat it bought it remember
shortly after I was convinced I'm gonna
die of hypothermia eating that for
riskier and just saying to you like I
can't communicate how nice this is
yeah it's hard to know how much of it
was like delirium it was it was early
onset pneumonia that sure whisky it was
like a pudding it's like a low calorie
protein filled pudding
what's the percentage of protein to
Cal's in ski or it'll be like 20% so you
know far hey 0% that is essentially a
protein supplement
it's like 50 grams of protein zero fat
in a turbo fire it is like eight quid
what will get you low tabla fighting was
it you know kilo with four double
deckers I make some mental
[Laughter]
so those meal snack is often they'll
have a meal which will be two ready
meals dumped into a big bowl with some
salad that's the meal and then it would
be just a little finish it would be a
malt loaf and a part of yogurt did and
then just like just squash something
there's that Chris me and audio
broadcast all have in common that is we
see yogurt is the cement to any hope
it's not well it's like something would
be weird but if you have it with yogurt
it's fine
yogurt to me is a non savory ketchup
[Laughter]
it's a garden yeah it's a garnish that's
the closest I've ever felt to like it a
religious pulling towards a belief like
yoga is it is a savory pepper yes I
believe in yeah y'all get August I do
you believe in yogurt
I believe in yogurt I don't like I put
it on all sorts like people if F goes at
me cuz I've had like the honey yogurt
put on to curry those sweet was like
well it's just bland
material you can put on three of the
little mini fires with a side of my
crust recon part honey I'm okay I mean
they're expensive they're they're a
treat but they're nice acidity say as
well fine
yeah cuz everyone wants to say fudge so
it's fr hey right Seth should we do one
more and then we'll do a quick round
cool so on one of the previous life
hacks I think I would have mentioned
that I store the naughty apps on my
phone
unlike the eighth page of apps you are
an idiot folder why'd you call the
folder so this is what the folders
called
don't believe on No so it's a little
raiding podcast
good times
and the idea is you go through it and
obviously you've got the timer thing on
it as well as screen time and you're
like oh I better just check Instagram
okay just the laborious isn't it was
highly friction you highly friction you
go always at the end and then you look
and you're like ah I've just been
reminded like and then by that point you
like if you still do it you think well
okay
at least I've made this choice
consciously and so it's the hack having
screen time next to it that's what's
right so I did that I'm just gonna step
further now thanks to George McGill and
just deleted Instagram from my phone and
just don't even notice that there's no
urge to I look attacked you and
reinstalling at some point but the only
reason I need to because I upload all of
my Instagram stuff from flew for desktop
and so stories so one of stories disease
the thing Luna doesn't support stories
like if it does that I would be
game-changer
I will feature on the next one about my
strategy for two fonts why I've got two
phones one social media device and one
not on my screen time even aggregating
them both has dropped significantly
because he phones yeah which is which is
bizarre I think I was actually there
having a second phone is reduced screen
time but it has because mindless
scrolling has been pretty laminated just
like and yet I've got actually for the
next I have [ __ ] loads of fun
reduction life hacks but right I'll do
so what was your one that just solves
your once f they're like I really won't
do and deleting Instagram like whatever
your whatever your vice app is yeah your
mindless thing that you check on and
replace it with something that's useful
like come though iBooks if you want a
real kick in the [ __ ] about phone use
right the lotus serum red light with
black mirror yeah it's a hold but the
latest series of black marriages listen
through season 5 yep the episode called
smithereens is I'm not ruin it but the
ending the firm
cool you just like like it's not it's
not some long drawn out like complex
like you know the ruby sick [ __ ] like
that
so it's about it's about phone use okay
very very hard-hitting quite a three
episodes long I know it's but they're
quite so when I watched the a couple the
first few hours lioness in a [ __ ] but
that usin think about mothers night now
yeah Charlie Brockett you know I've said
this before and say again Charlie
Brooker I've been watching him from
screen wipe to muse wiped it all of the
random [ __ ] he did like back in 2008
isn't observer isn't it very it's so
[ __ ] good to see someone who was
probably at the mercy of the BBC or yeah
John for one of the to like some reach
tight network like totally awesome
Arizona yes well there's an it got but
no no no no what he was doing scream
like oh and then he comes up with this
idea for black mirror and first one was
good second one was good then
Netflix come in big money third once
much is it it's just he's the excitation
as well there's [ __ ] raking it in now
and he's finally got a platform where
his visions I'm presuming he still
probably taking creative lead here like
where his visions are actually able to
be crit but they had the guy that was
the main villain out of Sherlock Holmes
that's the episode that right yeah yeah
like you swinging swinging your penis
alright there's like a pop star in one
of them I don't know like I bet login
polls in the next scene he's everywhere
I can't believe how are you becomes a
chiffon of Logan Paul it's his podcast
my impulse impulsive
I'll have to have a list about got
traffic hasn't he I was laughing at a
picture that I saw of like when you're
texting boys in class and there was a
shot of urgent exit required
which okay do you have you seen you made
a reference to that show and so I see my
beauty yeah yeah so everyone knows what
we're talking about the fear that we've
spoiled each other's experience yeah
have you seen the end of season no I
laughed at it and I thought oh we can
throw this in this should technically be
on a catch-up but well we've written
different all the listeners know a bunch
line of Gd if you need a new Netflix
series watch watch I'm gonna type it in
right now
how many black line of duty yeah oh and
one right you like that you vine I think
both of those shows constitute your life
hath given heart yeah watch the planets
Brian Cox is new one on BBC two I play
write more it's the equivalent of planet
Earth for the soul that's right Cox for
the solar system years and years on BBC
so really further concept takes a family
in current so like they talk about
practice it and things it's all it's a
drama and they fast forward time 10
years 20 years so like there's been
another financial crisis like one little
kid there's been nucular stuff has gone
on and it you just watch it and you just
have this a bit like I'm slightly oh
like there's something really happen
viscerally horrible bought the passing
of time quickly like Ricky Bobby
Rick and Morty the the show that would
instance interstellar where there's that
famous scene in it it's so gut-wrenching
cuz it's just like what were Matthew
McConaughey finds out that his
daughter's like 80s because they're in
the way you for to with a problem the
professor what what the passing of time
coming quickly but TV and film is is
playing on all of our fears of death so
it's not I just have this feeling like
I'm being bombarded with media that's
just telling me that like the next 10
years is gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ] know if we
ladies aren't bad things say what the
next 10 years are not gonna be [ __ ] if
this podcast continues growing at the
rate we can all [ __ ] off really soon
honestly please fill the shame
continue to share this upper-class
honestly continue to share the episode a
rail just build a station and we will
have a [ __ ] spaceship and everyone
will have a massive part several can
come you're all invited
right that's your safe limit yeah last
three I will do thank you fire so my one
it's another holiday one if you are
sunbathing might be on holiday might be
in the UK if we finally get some good
enough weather what you want to do to
ensure that you are facing the Sun
without any odd like angles because you
get like one side of your body's a
little bit too done in the day or
whatever it is what you want to do is
look at the way that the bed or seat is
aligned and you want to make sure that
the shadows cast by the seat are running
completely parallel with the seat so if
you have one of the legs chopping out
and underneath one of the the actual bed
or the seat that means it's an angle and
you want to continue turning continue
turning continue turning to that and
then for a nice little look great what
you can do is work out which direction
this one's going in and you want to add
maybe about sort of 15 degrees 20
degrees that's probably got your back
got longer - probably got about maybe
half an hour to an hour but until it
gets to the middle which means that
you've got two hours and or cooked both
sides of you evenly that's good equal
chance of screen cancer everywhere use
sunscreen use sunscreen always mine is
period eyes who you learn from or who
you listen to
so rather than having like ten people
that you listen to a bit or whatever
what I quite like doing is I'll go like
I'll I'll go all in on someone for like
a month in a bit and it's not something
I do on purpose but I love it so silence
yeah Anton but like you find someone you
- boy like and then you like write and
listen to podcast buy that book absorb
yourself in that world learn what you
want for my person and then move on and
then that way I think you get totally
exposed to its what we're saying about
you read a book that you get exposed to
the way that the ideas and stuff like
that some is greater than all other
parts on you against emails like that in
fact
Ryan holiday has a blog post about how
he
I think he calls it the the swarm theory
of learning and it's how he's like
become a military history expert and the
way that he did it was just by drowning
in military history stone and I do think
devil immersion well because of
availability bias and the echo chamber
effect and recency bias and all of these
things having a lot of information which
all ties in together actually is going
to reduce your requirement for recall
which means that your depth of
understanding will be better and your
recoil will improve when you start to
piece multiple things together yeah so
yeah that's it you need like whatever
you would it be like whoever you listen
to I think if you have total
understanding of the picture of what
they're trying to say and why they think
what they think yeah right that makes
sense and then you can move on in
something else rather than having like
it's like go all-in on Tim Ferriss like
just us in the same first podcast but
couple of wait for a couple weeks and I
bet you'll enjoy it a lot more than it
being bitty yeah nice yeah like it's
only really come together for me like
just the course I've done this year
because of like you learn the little sub
components over the years but don't
piecing together until everything final
again so I was gonna do that was yours
you can t realize your I was gonna do
another tech one but I found looking
intently over the next one year this is
something that I mentioned in a previous
podcast which was a story from my old
boss at work who I was talking to it and
honestly and came up a thing a little
email notification that said like urgent
with loads of capital letters and stars
and things and she just closed a guitar
quiet emoji ta so she she just closed
the window and I was like oh love was
urgency don't want to get that she was
like no I decide what is urgent not this
man everything has urgent was a
requester I like that is such an amazing
quote and it someone Tim Ferriss hi this
is well which is someone saying he can
attribute who it was but it's so now
I've got a quote from a quote from
someone who doesn't know who
your lack of planning does not
constitute my emergency so the life mark
is if someone comes running to you with
something that is burning for them but
you are working on something that is a
priority question whether that is
objectively an emergency or is it just
someone else's lack of planning that
doesn't have to become your emergency
now I like that and I guess as well it
means that even if you've followed a lot
of our strategies about turning off
notifications and checking your emails
periodically as opposed to ad hoc and
they arrive there will be a way that
someone else can gain that system oh
I'll go knock on your door
yeah it's having your phone call or
whatever 10 million avoids that from
happening but thank you very much for
tuning in
do not forget to whatever put the other
shaker do not apply equi not kombucha it
tastes like Satan's vinegar piss what
you should do the bottle of if shared
this episode and either tag me in a
share or show me a screenshot at the end
the actress will acts wherever you find
me
Sherry's I'm going to choose 5 people to
get one of these they're awesome thank
you very much the program works for
sponsoring this episode
and we will catch you next time we
haven't named the Koala qawalli oh the
middie a koala if you have any better
ideas to what we can call the Koala then
do it well yeah for now thank you very
much for tuning in
like share subscribe to all of that good
stuff I really appreciate it okay bye
then
[Music]
you